bon mes chers amis c'est pour moi un
immense plaisir d'être parmi vous et de
répondre à l'invitation de philippe
goujon
philippe président avec beaucoup de sang
froid
j'ai envie de dire beaucoup de
dévouement aussi parce que ça n'est pas
si facile
la première fédération de notre
mouvement c'est un ami c'est un
parlementaire qui ne transige pas sur
ces valeurs
et puis c'est un maire qui est engagée
24 heures sur 24
malgré les intempéries socialiste et je
voudrais le féliciter
je veux adresser à tous nos élus de
paris à tous nos militants parisiens un
message d'estimé et d'affection et
surtout ensemble nous fixer un cap
nous avons au fond trois missions à
accomplir
la première mission elle est simple
résister à madame tout va bien madame
tout va bien vous l'avez reconnu c'est
le maire de paris à l'entendre en effet
tout va bien et bien notre mission c'est
de lui faire entendre la voix des
parisiens c'est de lui faire entendre la
voix des parisiens qu'il intervient qu
ils interpellent sur leur travail et qui
leur pose la question qu'est ce que vous
faites pour les salariés qui veulent
travailler le dimanche plutôt que pour
que de s'appauvrir
la réponse de madame hidalgo vous la
connaissez c'est d'ailleurs une réponse
qui nous conforte dans l'idée que les
changements que nous devons apporter à
l'organisation de notre pays à l'avenir
doivent être des changements profonds
radicaux car on voit bien à quoi aboutit
le culte du compromis permanent ça
aboutit à la loi macron et la loi macron
ça risque d'aboutir à moins de liberté
pour ouvrir des commerces à paris qu
avant la loi macro notre mission c'est
ensuite de lui faire entendre
la peur des parisiens devant
l'insécurité qui progresse et qu'elles
refusent de combattre avec les moyens
qui sont à sa disposition
notre mission c'est de dénoncer sans
relâche
des conditions de transport et de
circulation qui deviennent
catastrophiques
notre mission c'est de nous faire les
interprètes de la colère des classes
moyennes qui ne sont ni assez riche pour
paris ni assez pauvre pour profiter de
ces aides sociales
notre mission au fond c'est d'exprimer
notre fierté déçu d'appartenir à une
capitale qui certes fait rêver le monde
entier mais qui en réalité pourraient
être bien plus prospère bien plus sûr et
bien plus rayonnante
je veux mes amis salué la résistance de
cette fédération de paris et le travail
de celles et de ceux qui vont passer la
main à une nouvelle équipe et je veux
adresser à frédéric péchenard tous mes
encouragements pour sa nouvelle mission
notre deuxième mission c'est de faire
gagner
valérie pécresse et pierre-yves
bournazel aux élections régionales
cette victoire en ile de france elle est
nécessaire pour relancer la dynamique de
la région capitale
elle est nécessaire pour apporter des
réponses aux maux dont souffrent les
parisiens parce que paris y étouffe dans
une région sans ambition dans une région
sans stratégie dans une région sans
autorité et enfin cette victoire aux
régionales elle est évidemment
indispensable pour engager l'alternance
politique dont notre pays a besoin
imaginez un instant que la gauche ne
subissent pas une défaite écrasante aux
élections régionales ce que monsieur
hollande en tirerait comme conséquence
et comme conclusion c'est que sa
politique finalement n'est pas si mal
que ça qu'il a toutes les raisons de se
représenter et surtout qu'il a toutes
les raisons de continuer encore pendant
18 mois dans la voix
faux ce qui l'en qu'il emprunte depuis
déjà maintenant près de trois ans et qui
conduit notre pays dans une impasse
si vous n'êtes pas convaincu peut-être
êtes-vous déjà cette semaine deux images
ont fait le tour du monde
la première montre est un responsable
d'air france en guenilles quasiment
lynché par des voyous qui confondent
manifestations et agressions l'autre au
parlement européen montre et madame le
pen
injuriant de façon grossière le
président de la république et la
chancelière allemande
et bien je vous le dis face à ces deux
images j'ai eu honte j'ai eu honte de
voir mon pays que j'aime présenter le
visage de la violence et de la haine
j'ai eu honte de voir mon pays d'un côté
prisonnier d'un pouvoir impuissant et de
l'autre condamné à subir les mensonges
de la firme le pen la vérité c'est que
nous ne sommes pas condamnés à subir les
erreurs socialiste et nous ne sommes pas
condamnés à avaler plus longtemps les
mensonges de la pme de la famille le pen
la france
la france est pas fichu c'est juste son
système qu'il est est un système ça se
change à condition d'avoir le courage de
gouverner les républicains c'est notre
mission ne doivent pas laisser le pays
s'enfoncer dans le marais et si nous
sommes tous rassemblés c'est parce que
nous sommes tous révoltés après trois
années de pouvoir
on peut déjà affirmer que le quinquennat
de françois hollande aura été
historiquement une calamité pour la
france est donc naturellement face à
cette calamité
nous devons envoyer aux élections
régionales en veut tant bien et
bournazel un message puissant à françois
hollande
ce message c'est monsieur le président
on va vous sanctionner parce que vous
n'avez pas cessé de mentir aux français
depuis le débat dès le début de votre
quinquennat
vous nous aviez dit que la crise était
conjoncturelle que les déficits allaient
être rapidement réduit que le chômage
allait bientôt décroître que la reprise
était là
ces promesses sont balayés par les faits
les faits c'est plus de six cent mille
chômeurs supplémentaires depuis 2012
les faits ces deux millions de jeunes
qui aujourd'hui dans notre pays ne sont
ni à l'école ni dans une formation ni
dans un emploi ça fait à peu près trois
mois que jasseines se chiffre à chaque
fois qu'un micro ce temps devant moi et
que je n'arrive pas à le faire sortir
dans le débat public
je vous demande à m'aider à le faire
parce que ce chiffre est le chiffre le
plus grave de tout ce que je vais
évoquer devant vous deux millions de
jeunes qui ne sont nulle part 2 millions
de jeunes qui sont quasiment dans la rue
il n'ya pas un autre grand pays en
europe qui puisse présenter un bilan
aussi négatif c'est une
bombe à retardement et cette bombe à
retardement elle est très largement la
conséquence des erreurs de françois
hollande et de son gouvernement qui ont
massacré le système d'apprentissage qui
ont refusé de corriger les errements de
notre système éducatif et qui s'entête
encore dans une réforme du collège qui
n'aura pas d'autre résultat que
d'aggraver la situation de la jeunesse
française 300 milliards de dettes
supplémentaires
la dette française va atteindre 96,5 %
ou 7 % du de la richesse nationale
ça va c'est des chiffres comme ça qui si
elle a l'impression que ça signifie rien
du tout je vais vous en donner un qui va
peut-être vous fait réfléchir
même si en même temps il me renvoie à
une longue carrière politique
quand j'ai commencé quand j'ai été élu à
l'assemblée nationale pour la première
fois la dette française
c'était 17 % de la richesse nationale
c'est aujourd'hui près de 100 % de la
richesse nationale
c'est un drame absolu qui condamne notre
pays à être dépendant des autres et face
à sa caisse que françois hollande nous
propose comme perspectives pour l'année
2016 est au fond la fin de son
quinquennat
à peine 1% de croissance une crise
identitaire qui amène les français à ne
plus croire en leur pays et une
politique étrangère qui est un désastre
pour l'image de la france et qui est un
désastre pour l'europe qui vous le voyez
est remise en cause par les flux de
réfugiés qui pourraient être stoppées
si la france et l'europe avaient le
courage de prendre en charge une
politique étrangère sérieuse et réaliste
au proche orient
et en votant pour valérie pécresse et
bournazel aux élections régionales il
faut aussi envoyer ce message à françois
hollande fait quelque chose les 18 mois
qui vous reste on ne peut pas nous
considérer qu'on est simplement un parti
politique qui attend l'alternance et se
réjouir de voir que pendant 18 mois la
situation du pays va continuer de se
dégager de se dégrader
donc notre message c'est aussi de dire à
françois hollande prenaient des
initiatives faites en sorte que ces 18
mois ne soit pas les 18 mois les plus
longs et les plus inutiles de la vème
république il ya un référendum qui a été
organisée dans une entreprise automobile
dans l'est de la france
une majorité de salariés a choisi de
repasser à 39 heures payées 37
monsieur le président de la république
prenait en compte l'avis des salariés
écoutez les prenez des initiatives pour
libérer le temps de travail dans notre
pays
les agriculteurs sont en train de
crouler sous le poids des charges et des
contraintes
je lui ai proposé une idée très simple
qui coûte absolument rien supprimés je
les ai même pas d'y supprimer gelé
toutes les normes qui pèsent sur
l'agriculture française et qui ne sont
pas exigible dans les autres pays
européens
juste ça ça suffirait à redonner de
l'espoir et de l'oxygène à l'agriculture
française
et puis enfin changer de politique
étrangère comprenait enfin que vos
postures morales conduisent en réalité à
des désastres que derrière vos postures
morales il ya des milliers et des
millions de gens qui souffrent de
l'hymne de l'incapacité de la france de
l'europe et de l'occident à comprendre
la crise du proche orient et à mettre en
oeuvre des politiques qui soient des
politiques efficaces et nous
continuerons on s'est enorgueilli
pendant 48 heures que nos valeureux
pilotes français soit allé frapper des
cibles en syrie c'est très bien mais qui
peut croire que en allant une fois tous
les quinze jours frapper une cible en
syrie on va régler le problème de la
syrie est ce que paient les flux
migratoires
elle nous envahir voilà la france qu'un
françois hollande promettait de ré
enchanter et bien c'est en fait une
france qui est aujourd'hui tourmenté par
les cauchemars ça fait un moment vous me
le reconnaîtrez que je nous alerte sur
le décrochage de notre pays j'avais dit
un jour que la faillite n'était pas une
menace
abstraites alors je sais la chanson
prétend que celui qui dit la vérité doit
être exécuté mais on n'abat pas la
vérité et vous avez sans doute remarqué
qu'il ya trois mois quand tout le monde
était au chevet de la grèce plus
personnes chantaient de cette crise le
président de la république oublie
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est que
pour qu'un peuple reste souverain pour
qu'il n'ait pas à subir la volonté des
autres ce qui au fond est en gros la
définition du gaullisme et bien il doit
se réformer par lui même et pour lui
même
non monsieur hollande nous ne sommes pas
souverain nous ne sommes pas avec 2000
milliards de dettes tenue entre les
mains de je ne sais quels fonds de
pension américains asiatiques ou qatari
souverain nous ne sommes pas lorsque le
gouvernement va tête basse à bruxelles
pour s'excuser de ne pas respecter ses
obligations en matière de déficit
souverain nous ne le sommes pas lorsque
la croissance française est juste
scotché sur celle de l'europe et celle
de l'europe
indexée sur celle des états unis s'ouvre
à nous ne le sommes pas lorsque nous
avons six millions de personnes qui
pointent à pôle emploi parce qu'on a
refusé de réformer le marché du travail
souverain nous ne sommes pas lorsque
notre partenaire allemand tient les
rênes de l'europe et pourquoi tient-t-il
les rênes de l'europe juste parce que
nous sommes incapables de le faire
nous-mêmes ou et la souveraineté
populaire
quand l'état recule devant les
délinquants comme nous venons encore de
le voir avec les drames qui se sont
produits dans notre région ile de france
cette semaine lorsque la laïcité c'est
devant les fondamentalistes lorsque les
syndicats les plus archaïques font la
loi
lorsque
je le cite est dans le débat avec le
premier ministre dans la région des pays
de la loire à côté de nantes depuis
maintenant plusieurs années un
territoire entier plus grand que
plusieurs communes est entre les mains
de hors la loi qui en administre le
territoire et qui filtre les gens qui
ont le droit de rentrer dans ce
territoire et ceux qui n'ont pas le
droit des hors la loi qui ont attaqué
comme au far west comme les diligences
un fourgon de gendarmerie il ya quelques
semaines
sorti les gendarmes et brûlé le véhicule
de la gendarmerie des hors-la-loi qui il
ya encore quelques jours ont intercepté
un camion de marchandises sur une route
publique de cette région
honte éjecté les chauffeur et se sont
emparés de la cargaison
voilà c'est en france que ça se passe
aujourd'hui la vérité c'est que ce
pouvoir n'a plus aucune autorité
et quand le pouvoir n'a plus d'autorité
c'est la souveraineté nationale qui est
menacée
voilà mes amis y aura pas de
redressement national sans réformes
radicales et aujourd'hui compte tenu de
la situation de notre pays je veux dire
que la france n'a pas seulement besoin
d'alternance politique elle a besoin de
faire tomber les bastilles qui étouffe
les énergies française il faut faire
tomber la bastille des 35 heures mais
faut pas la faire tomber à moitié il
faut la faire tomber complètement
il faut laisser les organiser les
salariés libres de négocier avec leurs
entreprises le temps de travail sans y
mettre de limites sans y mettre de
contrainte en faisant confiance en
faisant confiance aux hommes et aux
femmes qui travaillent dans les
entreprises françaises
la bastille du code du travail ensuite
il faut la faire sauter cette bastille
qui exclut ceux qui cherchent un travail
la bastille de l'impôt confiscatoire qui
décourage les talents et qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui notre pays soit à l'arrêt
parce qu'il n'y a plus d'investissement
comment considérer un pouvoir qui n'a de
cesse que de dénoncer ceux qui gagnent
de l'argent qui n'a de cesse que de les
pousser à s'exiler
je veux parler des capitalistes français
et qui lorsqu'ils cherchent des faux
pour relever des entreprises
stratégiques françaises va se rouler par
terre devant le qatar ou les fonds de
pension américains
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire d'un
gouvernement qui agit de cette manière
il faut faire sauter la bataille des
réglementations qui bloque l'innovation
la bastille de la dépense publique qui
conduit tout droit à la faillite
la bastille de l'égalitarisme qui est la
négation du mérite et du courage
la bastille de l'as la bastille de
l'assistanat qui détruit la cohésion
nationale partout où je vais en france
je vois la colère monte mais je vais
vous dire je vois la colère monte plus
que vous ne le pensez plus qu'on le voit
peut-être ici de notre capitale
nationale
les entrepreneurs les salariés les
chômeurs les agriculteurs les artisans
il ya dans toutes ses catégories de
français
révolte qui est en train de monter une
révolte contre l'immobilisme qui les
enfonce une révolte contre tout ce qui
ne marche plus et j'ose dire que jamais
notre pays n'a été aussi prêt à assumer
un vrai projet de liberté un projet
construit sérieusement un projet porté
par des équipe solide et déterminée il
s'agit pas de revenir en arrière
il s'agit pas simplement de corriger des
erreurs ou des excès il s'agit de
changer de logiciel
il s'agit de remplacer nos réflexes
étatique par l'ouverture de nouveaux
espaces de liberté et par un véritable
contrat de confiance avec les français
il s'agit de nous doter d'un logiciel
qui nous interdirait de réglementer de
légiférer de taxer quand une autre
réponse est possible d'un logiciel qui
au fond répondrait à cette
interpellation d'une femme dans une
réunion que je faisais ya quelques mois
je crois que c'était à toulouse et qui
m'a dit moi il ya une seule chose que je
vous demande que l'état soit loyale avec
nous avec nous et je lui ai dit mais
c'est quoi un état loyal elle m'a dit
c'est un état qui met pas des radars en
bas des descentes qui changent pas la
règle des règles de la fiscalité tous
les quinze jours qui ne met pas en place
des impôts rétroactif
c'est un état en qui on peut avoir
confiance
et bien c'est ça l'objectif qui doit
être celui des républicains vont
remettre l'état à sa place de recréer
une relation de confiance entre l'état
et les citoyens est au coeur de cette
relation de confiance y ait la liberté
voilà la situation française est
difficile mais parmi nous parmi les
républicains personne ne tremblent
devant cette situation il est temps
maintenant de s'engager
il est temps de miser sur la liberté sur
la confiance
il est temps d'apprendre à nos enfants à
aimer la france a aimé son histoire
complexe en engageant une autre
partition que celle de l'excusé obligé
il est temps de parler de la république
française et pas seulement de la
république tout court c'est pas si vous
avez remarqué mais nos gouvernants n'ont
que ce mot à la bouche
tous les jours il nous parle de la
république toutes les quatre phrases le
premier ministre prononce
le mot république il ne parle jamais de
la république française comme si la
république c'était une sorte d' idée
abstraite mais nous ne sommes pas une
idée abstraite
nous sommes la france nous sommes un
pays avec une histoire avec une culture
avec une identité avec une géographie
avec des espoirs avec des qualités avec
des défauts c'est la république
française et c'est cette république
française que nous devons apprendre à
nos enfants
voilà il est temps de sortir notre
drapeau de crier notre fierté d'être
français
celui qui sait d'où il vient celui qui
sait ce qui doit à son pays est bien
celui là il n'est pas le pion d'une
histoire qui se joue ailleurs
nous sommes au début d'une marche d'une
marche dont vous connaissez le but il
s'agit de nous renouveler
il s'agit de nous rassembler il s'agit
de faire gagner la france c'est notre
devoir c'est la bataille des parisiens
et c'est la bataille des français
je redemande la parole comme elle est en
face de moi
helm aveuglait et donc je n'ai pas vu
qu'elle était là et je n'ai pas cité au
début de mon propos nathalie kosciusko
morizet que je suis heureux de saluer et
qui conduit nos combats parisien contre
madame tout va bien